in massive volumes I can as it again as
a DJ you have to be a current and keep
aware of what's going on and that means
you know just massive amounts of
information so DJ is a kind of obsessive
about information I tend to think that
if you look at Michael Jackson he's the
Koala the King of Pop precise because
they had millions and millions of people
listen to the same record or same songs
if you play Billie Jean for example
everybody knows that even in India or in
Nepal or the most remote parts of
Timbuktu you know people know that song
so millions people listen up I'm the
opposite where it's like set of millions
of people listen to the same song its
millions of songs being scratched and
sliced and diced and you have to keep
track of it all so it's like the
information ocean or data cloud or just
you know there's I think itunes now has
passed its built several billion
download you know think of all those
people it's the biggest record store in
the world and amazingly enough to me
again as a DJ an artist the top-selling
album of all time right now is the blank
CD you know so you know it's number one
on every chart
I'm a big Pro Open Source Pro Creative
Commons kind of artist I think that it's
important to realize the copyright laws
as it's written relates mainly to the
eighteenth centuries relationship to
physical goods and as things move more
and more into a digital media
hyper-connected world we need to
transform the models of how we think of
ownership copyright law is something I
respect but the way the law is written
versus the way we live and this rip
makes burn kind of scenario you know
it's all about I think think of digital
music as the kind of new folk culture
where everyone should share and by
sharing they create a more rich and
robust narrative
yeah sure but I get value out of that I
get a different kind of value get
branding you get advertising you get
word of mouth viral marketing yeah you
know you can't you couldn't pay for that